[Musique]
je m'appelle à ramallah je suis seul à
l'aise je m'appelle les rôles à g ou
bien aux grands arrivé en france en 2010
est sa femme roula font partie des
quatorze stagiaires formés par prom'hôte
ifitel à chanteloup-les-vignes
passionnés de cuisine ils ont choisi de
se spécialiser dans ce secteur je suis
en formation depuis 28 octobre comme
mais j'étais petit je passais de noix
journée avec ma mère aux soudards je
fais les pâtisseries tjr grande plagne
en france
je voudrais au béret rouge restera très
cher comme beaucoup d'élèves ici tous
deux bénéficié de cette formation grâce
à activity lagence d'insertion rend
accessible ces stages pour des publics
habituellement éloignés de l'emploi
prom'hôte ifitel a donc conçu un
programme spécial mêlant cours de
français et cours de cuisine sa mission
former et accompagner les stagiaires
pour faciliter leur insertion sur le
marché du travail
c'est un son qui est spécialisée dans
les métiers de l'hôtellerie et de la
restauration
donc ils ont une centaine d'heures de
français langue étrangère donc si du
français à visée professionnelle et donc
de la technique une aire également on
leur achète et on leur offre une tenue
de cuisine et ils apprennent ils
apprennent les premières techniques les
premiers gestes en cuisine une formation
de deux à trois mois qui permettra à ses
stagiaires de devenir commis de cuisine
cuisinier ou agent de restauration
promod fait partie des 500 partenaires
de lagence d'insertion activity depuis
sa mise en place il ya un an après 2
centimes lino a pu bénéficier de ce
partenariat et repartent
effectivement avec un vrai bagage on
qu'on construit ensemble aussi des
suites des suites de parcours et c'est
ce qu'il ya de plus intéressant parce
qu'on sait qu'on se lève le matin
[Musique]
en trois ans la chance d'insertion
activity a permis à 5000 yvelinois de
reprendre une activité
elle a formé plus de 460 personnes
métiers de la restauration en deux ans
au total activity a mené deux mille
actions de formation sans partenaires
dont prom'hôte ifitel et 400 entreprises
lui font confiance